letztes jahr hat eine youtube wenn alles
gegeben unendlichen weiten der um das
sommerloch zu stopfen
denn wenn es warm wird und dass die
menschen nach draußen zieht ist sie zur
stelle
kleiner tipp
das eigentlich ziemlich bescheuert ist
denn wer macht schon videos seien es
kaum man guckt man könnte auch bequem
bis zur weihnachtszeit warten bis die
werbung wieder richtig kohle abwirft um
80 von produktplatzierungen kaum retten
kann
aber egal 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 nur hohes kommen
wir nun zur twitter frage
ja ich auf twitter gefragt wenn ihr
sofort eine maschine wie würden sie
helfen will eine frau main planen
der erste punkt auf unser ist ein
sommerloch macht euch bereit es geht
wieder los
richtig gut brauchen neues intro wie
wär's mit
aber das doch genau das gleiche wie
letztes jahr stimmen neues jahr neues
intro wie wäre es wenn ich
moment mal wo ist dein helm
ich hab keinen helm du hast also ohne
schutz mach ich's nicht
kein problem ich bin schnell ein verein
wie du stellst bestellen ein ja aber wir
sind morgen übermorgen nicht da also
morgen mit den katzen zum friseur
übermorgen auf dem fernsehturm kein
problem mit der neuen therme sap kann
ich meine bestellung ganz einfach nach
wunschtermin liefern lassen
dazu muss ich mich einfach auf der app
oder daher müsste ihr anmelden und
bekommen dann meine kundennummer
die ich bei der bestellung im onlineshop
immer das zusatz eingehen kann und wenn
man papier bereit ist kann ich den
liefertermin ändern oder ich lasse es
mir zu einem paketshop in der nähe
liefern
das braucht dort ist gut mehr dort ist
gut und bitte
es kommt zurück meine damen und herren
das sommerloch dem ein oder anderen ist
es vielleicht aufgefallen da war eine
versteckte kooperation dazwischen habe
ich ganz clever da drin versteckt ich
mal kurz auf die herren sap und die
wunsch zustellung eingehen wäre das noch
nicht ganz verstanden hat kann natürlich
in der infobox schauen da sind alle
links blind da könnt ihr nochmal alles
nachlesen also ich shoppe selber viel im
internet und in öfter nicht da dann bin
ich mal nicht da es gibt tage an denen
ich nicht da bin ich finde diese
funktion media praktisch du kannst die
nummer die kundennummer überall eingeben
die mit hermes liefern und dann können
sie dir das mit wunsch zustellung zu
schicken oder sie liefern sie ganz
normal die kriegszeit dann so eine
nachricht wann das geliefert kommt und
dann kannst du halt dich durchklicken
und aussuchen was du haben möchtest ist
das nicht toll
die zukunft rolle juli an dieser stelle
möchte ich danke sagen an hermes für die
kooperation und an euch da draußen ich
hoffe ihr seid mir nicht böse wenn mal
in videos eine versteckte werbung drin
ist ich bin ja auch nicht böse wenn ihr
mir meine app empfiehlt oder so also
immer her damit
es ist so was sagt ihr zu einer neuen
haarfarbe lasst uns mal youtalk reden
leute sagt man leute wie geht's denn
euch wir haben nicht gesprochen
als super euch gehts in katzen gut
ich gehe jetzt mal davon aus dass jeder
eine katze besitzt denn ansonsten
verstehe ich nicht warum wir auf diesem
planeten sind eigentlich urlaubspläne
dieses jahr ist ja ich fahre zum alle
aller alle alle allerersten mal alleine
in den urlaub also mit alleine meine ich
ohne die eltern denn ich fahre nicht
alleine ich fahre natürlich mit meinem
geheimen freut
wer könnte mein geheimer freund sei
die küsten sich so aber das eine ohr ist
ab katzen man liebt und liebt sie
dollar